hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in book three of Marcus
aurelius's meditations we find a long
passage that is not only very
interesting and revealing but you might
even say inspiring it's an exhortation
to get things right in one's head and
thereby within one's life in terms of
prioritization thinking about goods and
what we ought to pursue and before we
launch into it let me say that you can
see similar appeals coming up in later
authors who are not as Marcus Aurelius
is a stoic but you know for example
Christians like you're going to see a
similar reference being made to uh you
know if this isn't the highest thing
then find something better then it's
something greater than it in Augustine I
believe it's and On free choice of the
will and so this is kind of an
interesting thematic that's being done
an argument is being put forward to
himself and therefore to us readers
figure out what you think is actually
the highest the best the greatest
krachon in this the Greek term that's
used for that and if the thing that you
think is the best
turns out not to be so well then that's
okay go after whatever is the absolute
highest set your bar as high as it can
possibly go so it begins this is in
chapter six
if at some point in your life you should
come across anything better than now
notice the first thing that he's going
to say something could be better than
and it's going to turn out that there
isn't anything better than that if you
can find something greater than what
this looks like the listing of the four
cardinal virtues but there is an
important difference so we have Justice
decayo sune right in Greek then we have
truth alethea which is translated by
some translators as honesty meaning
truthfulness on one's own part but
there's no necessary reason to read it
that way it could be truth itself is
something to value and if that's the
case then we could easily view this as
appealing to the one virtue that deals
with that specifically which is is
wisdom or Prudence right and then we
have self-control so Frozen right
sometimes translated as Temperance or
moderation and courage or bravery Andrea
so if you can find something that is
better than those right and then he's
going to go on and talk about something
else that is presented almost as if it's
something different but it's really this
is the kind of way this matter would be
so mind the annoya right also it could
be translated as our intellectual
faculties a mind that is rational or
following reason and it's not just
following reason per se it's following
right reason kataton
orthos means correct straight right and
so this is a mind that is genuinely
rational not just just engaging as in as
we call them
rationalizations right where it's really
the desires that are running the show
and then we come up with reasons
afterwards no this is this is a mind
that is genuinely rational in accordance
with reason and accepts the right sorts
of things satisfied to accept what's
beyond its control
now these are closely connected right
because to have a mind that is genuinely
rational and accepting things that are
beyond our control means for Marcus and
for the stoics having these cardinal
virtues these four that are recognized
by not just the stoics but also by the
epicureans and the platonists and you
know quite a few other people along the
way as well so if we do find something
that's greater than that what should we
do
it doesn't mean like throw virtue away
right but Embrace that thing without any
reservations why because it's the best
thing and enjoy it as he says to the
full
but Marcus doesn't think that you are
going to find anything greater than than
this and this is within us so he says if
nothing presents itself that's superior
to the spirit the diamond that lives
within and now notice the thing that
he's going to say about this dimona
there's actually five different
qualifications
so one is that it has subordinated
individual desires and you're going to
notice that there's a lot of talk here
about subordinating or subjecting and so
a lot of this has to do with the
terminology of arrangement so you are
arranging yourself subordinating
individual desires EDS
now this is a technical term in stoicism
horme is often translated as impulse or
choice so desires works but your own
individual idios your own particular
choices your own commitments you're
subordinating that to a greater whole
which is this dimon right this spirit
one that discriminates among Impressions
so Impressions another technical term
Fantasia right
um this is is quite important as well
and so you know Impressions appearances
imaginations the stoics thought that one
of the characteristic things about human
beings as rational animals is not only
that they take in Impressions use them
the way that animals do but that we
judge them we discriminate between them
some of them we say that's not the way
things are even though they appear to be
that way so this is part of having that
self-control he also talks about bro
having broken free of sense Temptations
aestheticon pesseon right now
aestheticon means of the things that we
we use as our senses sight taste hearing
smell touch right and so Temptations
things that we would want to follow
could be anything from like watching too
much TV to you know needing to be
surrounded by one wonderful odors that
we get by buying all these essential
oils and sprinkling them everywhere
don't you know dosing ourselves with
perfume or cologne or products we could
go on and on and on so it's broken free
of these and in so doing it is
subordinated itself again we see this
language of subordination to the gods to
the higher beings that are models for
ourself and then finally looking out for
human welfare uh human beings welfare
the term there is is anthropos so a
sense of humanity right which is
contained by the way in these four
cardinal virtues so you know Marcus is
saying this is what you are this is what
you can Discover at least in potential
within yourself and it since you can't
find anything higher than this well then
you do need to like face the
consequences what is that then don't
make room for anything but that for
anything that might lead you astray
tempt you off the road and leave you
unable to devote yourself completely to
achieving the goodness that is Uniquely
Yours and this is actually echoing
something coming from Epictetus coming
from the very first and second parts of
the N Caribbean where he says listen you
know you can pursue what's in your
control which includes the things that
are up to you your character or you can
like attach yourself to all sorts of
external things you can try to have it
all you won't have it all if you devote
yourself to both of them you'll probably
miss out on both of them so which of
these is actually better which of these
Falls within the scope of the diamond
the mind the the virtues right we need
to you know prioritize and so he gives
you some examples of this the Applause
of the crowd you know social status and
celebrity uh High office remember this
guy is in fact at the highest office
that that's possible wealth
self-indulgence in Pleasures these are
the sorts of things that can lead us
astray and so we need to be careful we
don't necessarily need to reject them
entirely but we do need to break their
temptations that they have over us right
says it would be wrong to let anything
stand between you and attaining goodness
as a rational being and as a citizen all
of these might seem to be compatible for
a while with
pursuing what's what's Best But as he
says suddenly they control us and sweep
us away so we have to make a decision
right hello uh grab onto select
something and he says make your choice
could be translated as straightforwardly
but once is actually the more literal
translation haplos simply make your
choice now make your choice once and for
all and make it freely
not being compelled by someone else
choose what is actually the best
and not just the best per se but the
best for me he has a place in here where
he says the what is good is what is
beneficial right some Ferron and he says
best is what befits me and then we have
to follow through on this follow through
on that choice and there's two different
ways we could do that he says as a
rational being well then follow through
on it think your way to this when you
start getting tempted think well what is
better than virtue or a good personality
or character right uh if you want to do
it just as an animal he says then say so
and stand your ground without making a
show of it just make sure you've
actually prepared first so this is a
passage about putting things into a
final perspective for ourselves and then
choosing to follow out the consequences
of that by the way we arrange the
various things that we
consider valuable within our lives